what's up everybody welcome to the
behind the scenes for the bouncy ball
falling out of control video
one day sam and i were sitting around
and we thought hey you know what's fun
shooting things on the gopro gimbal you
know would be really fun is if we shot a
video from the perspective of a bounce
ball as it was bouncing around so we
started the video at little tokyo mall
in a public location the biggest thing
that we faced when having to get the
shots here was to keep the people in the
frame sam would start out and do the
first shot and then he would immediately
turn and come back and do the second
shot so that the same people were in the
first shot were also in the second shot
instead of trying to avoid those
problems we figured that it's better to
just embrace them wherever possible
within the script so the next location
we visited was pershing square which is
right in downtown los angeles we love
this location because it has buildings
all around and it's right in the middle
of the city it's easily recognizable by
people that are from here the first shot
coming into the park the next shot
moving through the park third shot
bouncing around and going crazy and then
shooting off and landing into carson's
mouth and then bam the security officers
showed up and they said hey you bunch of
boys can't be filming out here like this
this just ain't right you gotta do this
with a permit you know oh just come on
just come on let's let us get one more
shot well you see if i let that happen
my secure my officer might come down
here and like reprimand me and i don't
want to ride a report so let us get one
more and then we'll be out of your hair
and you want to write a report how old
are you son i don't know and then we ran
off and we shot the last shot and we got
out of that location
the la river is interesting because you
always have interesting characters there
we had a crackhead singing in the tunnel
and then you're going to be out of frame
when sam comes to about over here
because you're gonna turn sam
okay
you're gonna turn
now the la river is great
and it's
free and fun to film at if you know how
to get down there
[Music]
post
production post post post post post
production post production post
production
all right do not put that in there so
even though we shot this on a gimbal we
still applied warp stabilization because
it helps sell the overall concept after
we finished the effects carmichael did a
great job on the sound sam did a great
job on the music and now you're here
enjoying this video and if you like this
content consider subscribing check out
the links in the description below and
we hope to see you soon
jake what's it like returning to the gta
character
it's an honor really
every time i put on this costume i don't
know if i'm gonna like
go on a
get a phone call or
beat somebody up for money or
hurt an old lady or shoot someone you
know
it's uh it's just that kind of
[Music]
that kind of craziness this crazy world
don't use any of this